in extremely not surprising news to
start with today contrary to what the
Trump is right and even some people on
the Left have been saying some
investigators of Robert molars are now
saying that the four-page letter that
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
Barr put out does not accurately portray
their findings this is it's so obvious
and it was always so obvious that I'm
kind of embarrassed that there's even a
debate about this within the left like I
knew obviously when William bar wrote
this political press release of a letter
we knew it was meant to be used to have
a victory lap sort of exoneration party
by Donald Trump and the people around
him obviously it made no sense at
minimum because one of the few molar
quotes that was actually in bars letter
actually says molar was not able to
exonerate Donald Trump from obstruction
obviously Trump and people around him
eventually understood that the molar
report isn't so great for Trump because
they shifted from being all about
transparency and the release of the full
report to trying to obstruct its release
within the Senate at the Justice
Department and it absolutely every level
now I got some calls last week and I got
some emails this week that say David
don't you think that if the bar letter
mischaracterizes the molar report molar
would be out there front and center
saying they're not telling the truth and
the answer as I told one of our callers
last week is no molar said nothing the
entire probe molars spokesperson
clarified one news report by saying some
of the descriptions of specific
testimony supposedly made to the special
counsel are not totally accurate that's
all we heard from Robert Muller's
spokesperson during the entire
investigation
Moeller has not spoken there's no reason
to think molar all of a sudden is going
to start speaking unless he has to
testify before the house which he might
and we'll get to that next week but a
New York Times report
now says that molars investigators are
not staying silent
unlike molar himself and they are saying
what anybody with any common sense has
known for two weeks now which is that
the molar report is worse for Trump than
bar claims and it's definitely worse for
Trump than Trump claims now I told you
last week and I told you again this week
the whole point of this bar letter is to
first create a narrative
okay bar creates a narrative a story
with this letter which Donald Trump then
uses to run around the country claiming
that he's been exonerated the right-wing
media Falls for it most corporate media
Falls for it even some left-wing media
falls for it and now here come his
investigators molars investigators and
they say you know we're concerned
because now William bar has created the
first narrative he got the first
perspective out even though it's not an
accurate perspective the public might be
set in the belief that this is the
narrative the public has been primed and
you have other investigators now saying
shockingly right a lot of the material
in the Moller report should have been
included in that four-page summary if we
wanted it to be an actual complete
representation of what it is that the
investigation found and of course once
again this is all exactly according to
plan and completely unsurprising I think
the phrase you used yesterday Pat but
Pat was prime the pump this is now a
situation where of course the report is
more damaging to Trump than Barr claims
but they have all successfully primed
the pump where I don't even know if the
full truth of the Moller report will be
believed when it finally comes out if it
does well I suppose there's a range of
possibilities here like one on one side
you have the bar letter being pretty
accurate right and the 400 pages mostly
has to do with Russia interfering in the
election not so much Russia colluding
with Trump on the other end of the
spectrum there is this idea that Muller
had a good amount of evidence but not
quite enough to indict Trump and he had
quite a bit of evidence on obstruction
of
- but just didn't want to make the
recommendation wanted to leave that up
to someone else so I mean we won't know
for sure until the Miller report comes
out but certainly this story suggests
that it's the truth is far more on one
side of the spectrum than the other yeah
only in a fantasy world of blinding
political partisanship or deliberate
malignant ignorant could someone think
anything other than it's got to be worse
than Barre said you don't need 400 pages
to say Trump did nothing wrong you don't
say that you can't clear Trump of
obstruction if Trump did nothing wrong
and barn you this so they got a summary
out that was as good as possible for
Trump they used it to create a national
media tour of this faux victory lap
exoneration stuff while working to
stifle the release of the report and
here we are today were even some people
on the Left think that the report has
vindicated Donald Trump this was bars
job bar was chosen as Attorney General
because he doesn't believe a president
can be indicted for obstruction and to
cover-up the results of the probe he's
done it period and now Democrats are
going to need to keep fighting to get
the full report released which is what I
want to talk about next one of the day's
sponsors is privacy dot-com / Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a david
pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my
credit-card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy comm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link